in 2021 the IPO pipeline was flowing
with record volume an IPO or initial
public offering is the traditional way a
company goes public by listing shares on
a stock exchange and last year IPOs
raised more money than ever one of the
biggest IPOs since Alibaba biggest IPO
of 2021 but by December a broad sell-off
in high growth stocks led to two-thirds
of those in the U.S trading below their
IPO price and now the IPO pipeline is
seemingly Frozen
we haven't seen this slow a year in
terms of money raised and since at least
2009
that's because Sky High inflation Rising
interest rates and Russia's invasion of
Ukraine have made the financial markets
volatile and in turn made investors wary
of risky assets like IPOs at everything
that you could think of that would make
launching an IPO unpalatable like it was
happening and now analysts are worried
that if it doesn't turn around soon the
IPO freeze could carry over into the new
year
so far this year traditional IPOs have
raised only around 7 billion dollars in
a typical year traditional IPOs would
have raised around 38 billion dollars by
this time and at this time last year the
number was closer to 120 billion several
major companies including two fintech
giants had anticipated going public in
2022 before the pipeline froze and their
valuation shriveled up with it it was
supposed to be the year of the fintech
company there were many in the pipeline
ready to go we have not seen them
karna Bank a b was one of those highly
anticipated IPOs but instead of making a
splashy debut the sweden-based company
laid off hundreds of workers to cut
costs and was forced to seek funding in
private markets it's more than 45
billion valuation dropped by 85 percent
down to 6.7 billion dollars clana
declined to comment on its IPO plans
instacart also had to slash its
valuation in this case by around 70 to
13 billion dollars however with its
growing Revenue instacart was among a
few companies still hoping for some heat
and the opportunity to go public this
year there's a renewed focus on show
that you can become profitable if not
right now very soon
but the company reeled back its
Ambitions in late October in a memo to
employees instacart CEO said that
tumultuous market conditions are making
an IPO for the company highly unlikely
in 2022 but one area that has broken
through the ice this year is spin-offs
this is what a larger company separates
one of its subsidiaries or branches into
a separate public company Intel
self-driving car unit mobilei is one of
those IPOs expected to come through
after purchasing the unit for around 15
billion dollars intel was expecting a
mobile evaluation near 50 billion
dollars last year but today Intel is
expecting a Target valuation under 20
billion dollars Intel CEO has said that
listing mobile I would give the
self-driving car unit a higher profile
and attract more business he has also
said that Intel doesn't need the money
mobilized IPO would generate but
mobileye wouldn't be the first IPO in
the Auto industry to go public in this
weather Porsche launched on the
Frankfurt exchange at the end of
September though it's not a US IPO many
analysts agreed that if Porsches went
well it would be a positive sign for the
US IPO Market however Porsche's IPO I
wouldn't call a raging success yes it
priced at the high end of its range but
shares didn't do very well didn't have a
great pop that pop she's talking about
is how Bankers evaluate their initial
pricing strategy they look for a pop to
show momentum but not too big of one
that would signal money was left on the
table Porsche declined to comment on its
IPO the joke is how you price an IPO
it's an art not a science as they say
you want to see shares go up maybe not
you definitely don't want to see them
double the first day but you want to see
them rise now investors will look for
green shoots signals that the market is
warming up however the indicators of
today may look different than recent
years in 2020 2021 you could go to
market with a dream and a vision of how
you were going to make money and how you
were going to grow so fast that isn't
going to cut it in 2022 and 2023 or at
least doesn't look like it will cut it
the electric vehicle truck company
rivien is viewed as one of the last big
IPOs before the market crashed it scored
evaluation so high that meant it was
more valuable than Ford you're starting
to see cracks in the U.S economy
remember just a couple weeks after
rivien that's when the stock market
started really shifting and selling down
a lot rivian's stock price has since
come down the company was hit with a
lawsuit for allegedly misleading
investors about electric vehicle prices
and recently it recalled around 13 000
vehicles for loose Fasteners rivien did
not respond to a request for comment
historically IPOs are viewed as one of
the riskiest asset classes because
you're investing in a brand new company
few have a history of profits however a
flowing IPO pipeline means companies are
raising more money which can lead to
more hiring investing in Tech and
employees finally getting to cash in on
their stock options
so what would it take to thaw the IPO
pipeline success begets success so you
just need to see a string of IPOs do
well to encourage more companies to want
to go public but even as some look to
push the pipeline forward the broader
Financial Market remains volatile IPO
bankers and lawyers agree they say the
first companies to go public after the
markets calm down should be profitable
fairly large and must own names it all
comes down to appetite for risk when
investors are comfortable stomaching at
risk the IPO Market is strong and the
economy usually looks stable as well
foreign